men don't necessarily visualize women as
being at the top they their mental image
of the leadership of their organization
is often a clone of themselves one
example is the first board that I was
actually appointed to which was the
board of the snowy mountains engineering
Authority in Australia and this was a
group of engineers who had been
instrumental in building the great snowy
mountain scheme in Australia and had
then become a company owned by the
Commonwealth of Australia and I was the
first woman that was appointed to the
board and at my first board meeting a
senior member of the staff perhaps
reflecting some of my fellow board
members anxieties came up to me and said
look girlie what would you know about
engineering anyway how come the
Commonwealth has appointed you to be a
member of this board which was
incredibly rude but it was also a
reflection I felt of what a lot of the
senior management were thinking what on
earth could she bring and I thought then
I had to in a sense work much harder to
justify my contribution
whereas I suspect a man in the same
position wouldn't have had those sort of
challenges we used to talk about it
being the right thing to do to have
equal number of women on boards then
then after the series of research
efforts by people like the Conference
Board of Canada and others it was not
only the right thing to do it's the
bright thing to do because what we're
seeing is that the bottom line is
improving so so you've got it's the
right thing to do it's the right thing
to do then interesting research that was
done in Australia has proven that if we
actually had full female participation
we would improve the country's
performance by 12% the productivity of
the country now suddenly that gets even
the most
let me say misogynist person interested
in the fact that this might actually
have an economic effect it's this
productivity argument that has is moving
some of the people even if they don't
even want a woman on their board they
don't like women on their boards they'll
understand that it perhaps is getting to
the point where it's their fiduciary
duty to do that for the productivity of
their enterprise and for the
productivity of the nation